[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos de restaurantes
tradicionales y de gastronomía
vegetariana luego iremos al campo para
ver cómo los agricultores están
enfrentando la sequía que golpea
actualmente a francia y terminaremos en
lille en el norte del país para
descubrir el emprendimiento de dos
mujeres que se dedican a reciclar
brasiles
en el siglo 19 surgió un nuevo tipo de
restaurante el audio en parís hubo
prácticamente unos 250 y a pesar del
tiempo algunos sobrevivieron e incluso
hay otros que están abriendo sus puertas
en otras ciudades del país como por
ejemplo en dijo eso si mantienen la
misma fórmula es decir platos
tradicionales franceses a muy buen
precio y sobre todo en una decoración
digna de la belle époque veamos el
siguiente reportaje en parís estos
restaurantes hacen parte de la cultura
gastronómica a la francesa los bullón
que ahora también están llegando a las
regiones hace poco uno abrió sus puertas
en grenoble siguiendo la más pura
tradición sillas de madera iluminación y
precios muy atractivos uno de los
últimos en haberse inaugurado está en la
ciudad de edición hoy tenemos pasta con
lechuga de pollo y unas verduras añadió
aquí también se respetan los códigos y
el ambiente y solo se sirve comida
tradicional cabeza de ternera en salsa
ribis huevos con mayonesa pasta con
kinect con jamón en los bullón las
viejas recetas se vuelven a poner de
moda
durant es muy típicos de francia
es un poco la antítesis de la cocina
fusión de la cocina que está de moda con
productos de moda es una cocina un poco
más popular más sencilla y más eficaz y
eficaz las recetas se hacen con
productos frescos de estación y los
platos son muy caseros
una fórmula por aquí y los puerros
marinados buen provecho
y la calidad es muy buena y los platos
son sencillos es realmente agradable el
apio es como el que se puede hacer en
casa
ahora prefiero comer cosas sencillas
pero que estén bien hechas con buenos
productos en vez de buscar platos más
elaborados es muy actual aunque las
recetas sean antiguas eso es lo que me
gusta de este restaurante
son los sabores del pasado porque la
historia de los millones es de larga
data y se remonta a finales del siglo 19
hace más o menos un siglo en los
mercados parisinos había carniceros que
ofrecían trozos de carne los ponían a
hervir en agua para darle de comer los
trabajadores a unos precios muy
atractivos y los platos se servían muy
rápido para que pudieran volver a
trabajar y
desde entonces los platos han
evolucionado pero el rasgo económico se
mantuvo dos euros con 90 los huevos
mayonesa 11 euros con 90 la salchicha
con puré aquí hay todo tipo de clientes
somos aprendices estamos un poco en el
mundo obrero y en particular la fachada
me hace pensar en eso
llegué vi la carta y pensé que bueno
porque cuando uno es estudiante no
siempre tiene mucho dinero
el presupuesto promedio para comer en un
guión ronda los 18 euros en dijon y los
16 en parís una diferencia que se
explica por la cantidad bastante más
alta de clientes potenciales que hay en
la capital cada vez más personas dejan
de consumir carne e incluso quienes ve
tan por completo las proteínas animales
de su dieta esos son los veganos es todo
un movimiento que ha tomado bastante
fuerza sobre todo entre los más jóvenes
y ante esto pues hay muchos chefs aquí
en la francia que están ideando recetas
para complacer a esos comensales en el
país hay unos 150 establecimientos que
ofrecen una alta cocina ciento por
ciento vegetariana lyon tierra de los
típicos restaurantes buzón del buen
comer y de los embutidos pero en la
ciudad también existe un lugar
sorprendente un restaurante de alta
cocina 100% vegetariano no sirven ni
carne ni pescado un reto para adrián
ciudad un joven chef de 27 años que se
ha convertido en un experto de las
verduras
para un chef es apasionante porque a
nosotros nos anima la creación hacer
cosas que los no han hecho
y usted es vegetariano yo soy
vegetariano además ahora no hay que ser
vegetariano para comer comida
vegetariana
todos hemos reducido nuestro consumo de
carne y pescado como muchos franceses y
ahora la gente también quiere consumir
cosas diferentes de vez en cuando a
montón le gusta descubrir nuevos sabores
qué bien huele y distintas hierbas en la
fe esta se llama hoja de ostra tiene la
particularidad de tener el sabor de una
ostra pero en una hoja pidieron dos
canapés
en el menú de hoy una entrada con
champiñones
es una muselina de champiñones con
pétalos de cebolla de rosco pelo de
leche de champiñón al vino amarillo con
un fondo a la berza a la berza un menú
único a 35 euros con siete platos para
almorzar por favor las reservas en el
restaurante se hacen con dos meses de
antelación y los comensales no son solo
vegetarianos
confieso que soy más carnívora que
vegetariana la idea era descubrir platos
diferentes y verduras que no suelo comer
los sabores y la manera de combinarlos
están muy bien
me parece que hay buenas combinaciones
de sabores está bueno la presentación es
sublime entonces siempre dan ganas de
comerlo se tiene la impresión de estar
en un muy buen restaurante de alta
cocina un tipo de gastronomía cada vez
más popular en esta escuela de
hostelería las clases de cocina
vegetariana ahora hacen parte del
programa de alcachofa sal pimienta y un
poquito de vino blanco el objetivo es
darle un poco de acidez para mantener el
color
está claro que se trata de una petición
de los alumnos son mucho más conscientes
que nosotros que las generaciones
anteriores sobre los productos y la
calidad del medio ambiente
para estos alumnos apasionados la cocina
vegetariana es un hecho evidente
creo que es la cocina del futuro y que
se va a desarrollar además todavía hay
muchas cosas por hacer en este campo
entonces es emocionante porque todo está
por crear por inventar otros van aún más
lejos estos postres están hechos sin
mantequilla ni leche ni huevos se venden
en una pastelería 100% vegana en parís
que atrae a una clientela muy amplia
si hubiera sabido que es una pastelería
vegana de todas maneras habría entrado
tal vez no no lo sé pero cuando uno ve
esto tan bien presentado dan ganas de
comprar está bueno
si yo prefiero el sabor de los postres
aquí que en una pastelería clásica
hacer pasteles sin grasas de origen
animal un reto que asumió rodolf land o
meant vegano y pionero de este tipo de
cocina
vamos a hacer un merengue sin huevos se
parecen a los huevos pero no lo son
lo voy a mezclar trabajando con
ingenieros agrónomos encontramos una
proteína muy similar a la albúmina es la
proteína de papa que cumple las mismas
funciones atrapa el aire es una
alternativa a las claras de huevo que
sube muy bien a punto de nieve aquí está
la prueba
nada mal un merengue igual al original
para terminar de decorar esta tarta de
limón totalmente vegana
comprar ropa de segunda mano pasó de ser
una tendencia sobre todo entre los
adictos a la moda a convertirse en algo
habitual ahora en lille en el norte de
francia dos emprendedores francesas que
buscan darle una segunda vida a los
brasieres ellas recuperan las prendas en
boutiques donde la gente va a depositar
esas prendas que ya no utilice y luego
de reacondicionar las las vuelven a
poner en el mercado y las venden a mitad
de precio nuestra idea para francia es
ofrecer los primeros sujetadores cero
desechos y accesibles para todas las
mujeres para eso recogemos sus
sujetadores los reparamos y los de
vendemos
demasiados viejos pasados de moda o
dañados todos tenemos sujetadores
guardados hace tiempo en el fondo de
nuestros armarios louis jean black de
inmediato se sumó a la idea de darles
una segunda vida ya tengo cuatro
sujetadores para donar algunos están
rotos como éste y los demás han estado
en mis cajones durante años además creo
que ahora cambio un poco de tamaño de
copa y ya no sé qué hacer con ellos hoy
es el día de la entrega
louis se encontró una tienda cerca de
azúcar que tiene un punto de recolección
para las prendas aquí hay un punto de
recolección son los tengo unos
sujetadores viejos que quisiera dejar
muy bien muchas gracias es este de aquí
en lila y 8 tiendas con puntos de
recolección esta comerciante se ofreció
como voluntaria para apoyar la
iniciativa las personas están contentas
de que ofrezcamos una solución para un
desecho suplementario que tiene en la
casa y con el que no saben qué hacer
cada 15 días margo plus y maite free las
dos jóvenes emprendedoras de tras el
proyecto recogen las prendas seis meses
después de su inicio está claro que las
mujeres de bill han recibido la
iniciativa con entusiasmo desde que lo
creamos debemos haber recuperado unos
8.000 y el proyecto continúa entonces
las personas pueden seguir dando en los
sujetadores
8000 sujetadores que hay que clasificar
y limpiar mari embargo hacen todo en la
sala de su casa la limpieza es la clave
del reacondicionamiento
las clientas deben tener la garantía de
que todo lo que salga del taller está
lavado y limpio como si fuera una prenda
nueva hay que volver a quitar el relleno
aquí hay una mancha que hay que limpiar
muy bien
al principio recibieron consejos de una
costurera profesional ahora ya son
expertas
[Música]
hay que acortar un poquito los elásticos
y cada pieza tiene su particularidad
este sujetador está casi intacto pero
hay que cambiar los tirantes en nuestro
pequeño taller vamos a buscarle otros y
va a quedar como nuevo
cuando la reparación debe ser minuciosa
dos estudiantes de una escuela de moda
se encargan de trabajar las costuras
este sujetador tiene un nuevo broche que
era de otro que se iba a desechar los
tirantes se pueden recuperar entonces
todavía hay mucho material
encaje metal plástico la mezcla de
materiales impide que las prendas se
puedan reciclar entonces esta pequeña
empresa optó por la única solución
posible darle una segunda vida a esta
ropa interior
garantizamos que los dos sujetadores son
de buena calidad además son mucho más
baratos que uno nuevo y también son muy
ecológicos socios de color y última
etapa antes de ponerlos en venta en la
página web la sesión de fotos
y
sí
una vez reacondicionados los sujetadores
son un 40% más barato que los nuevos es
un gesto por el planeta clair se dejó
tentar por la iniciativa
[Música]
la talla está perfecta se nota que la
calidad es buena y los acabados están
muy bien se parecen a los sujetadores
que se compran en las tiendas y como la
idea es no generar desechos las partes
más dañadas se transforman en gomas para
el pelo y accesorios de moda
hasta aquí esta edición de francia en
foco gracias por acompañarnos continúen
con nuestra programación en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom